dans cette position les blancs
paraissent complètement foutus puisque
leur roi est sur le point de se faire
mater par la dame noire et qu'ils ont
deux tours de moins pourtant il existe
une extraordinaire combinaison de maths
en 9 coups je vais aller chercher avec
un petit indice un des deux cavaliers
blancs de endosser son costume de
super-héros pour voler sur les chiffres
je te laisse mettre pause et maintenant
voici la solution tout commence par un
incroyable sacrifice de dames d'un mètre
5 échec le but est d'attirer le roi noir
sur les cases de fourchette cavalier 7
on sacrifie le cavalier pour
désorganiser les pièces lourdes des
doigts et maintenant Pégase en troncelle
fourchette numéro une le roi recule on
mange la tour fourchette numéro 2 le roi
avance on mange l'autre tour fourchette
numéro 3 Royal cette fois-ci le roi
revient sur ses pas on capture la dame
mais c'est pas fini on a une égalité
matérielle il faut donc continuer le roi
avance le cavalier l'estomac bien rempli
poursuit ses échecs il vient terminer sa
danse en dessin et maintenant c'est le
pion G4 qui vient délivrer le coup de
grâce un superbe échec et mat en 9